dr. Anthony Falchi predicts a hundred
thousand to two hundred thousand dead
from coronavirus in the United States
China's lies continue and president
Trump extends his social distancing
measures to the end of April I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn surf the web with peace of
mind sign up now and expressvpn comm
slash man especially considering you're
now spending 98% of your waking time on
the Internet use Express VPN calm slash
Ben well before we get to the news you
may have noticed that the stock market
has been a little bit volatile and by
that I mean that it lost like one third
of its entire value over the course of
the last six weeks and now it's bumped
up a little bit but it's gonna bounce
down again because the fact is that we
don't know what course coronavirus is
going to take at this point we're not
gonna we're not sure what kind of
stimulus packages are gonna be necessary
in we're not sure what the stock market
is going to do even after all of that
because somebody's gonna have to foot
the bill for all of us this might be a
good time to think about maybe
diversifying at least a little bit into
precious metals so what exactly are you
waiting for you shouldn't just rely on
the stock market that would not be the
smart move instead call Birch gold right
now and talk to them about the
possibility of investing in precious
metals or converting your traditional
IRA or 401k into a precious metals IRA
if you haven't yet taken the first step
of requesting a free information Kanaan
gold you should know this is not a
complicated process for you Birch gold
will go to work make things super simple
they'll have a conversation with you you
can determine if precious metals make
sense for you there's no obligations you
have nothing to lose to take that first
step
Birch gold group thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau don't wait until the market drops
more to protect your hard-earned savings
text Ben - 47 47 47 today to see how
simple and straightforward this move can
be for you check for text Ben - 47 47 47
today - see how simple and
straightforward move can be for you and
check them out at birchgold.com slash
Ben that is birchgold.com slash Ben
alright so first we begin I hope that
you had a wonderful weekend or at least
a somewhat relaxing weekend given the
fact that there is nothing to be relaxed
about I mean if you're not having
nightmares that's point if you are not
nervous if your blood pressure isn't
higher than really good for you and
please tell me how you're doing it
because the reality is that well concern
is absolutely normal panic is not out of
the question given all the news that has
been coming in you know the fact is that
you can't watch the footage from New
York City where you are seeing hospitals
that are beginning to be overrun you're
saying emergency rooms that are full
you're seeing coronavirus patients or
racking up in these er as you're seeing
tape of people being being you know
moved out in body bags to morgues and
all this stuff is supremely scary and
then you look at the pictures of the
empty streets in New York City and Los
Angeles and I mean this is different
than anything in living memory for
people in the United States probably for
literally everyone for and because how
many people actually remember the
Spanish flu pandemic and even during the
Spanish flu pandemic one of the big
issues is that there was no nationwide
shutdown which is why the thing became
so deadly in the first place and nobody
has ever seen anything like this it's a
global thing right now I mean what we
have seen globally is the streets
cleared everywhere from the UK to Israel
to Italy I mean it's just all over the
planet people are hunkering down and
basically waiting for summer to come and
hoping that it kills off this virus
right now the latest statistics on
coronavirus are that globally we now
have 740 1914 cases so almost three
quarters of a million cases of
coronavirus that have been diagnosed we
have 35,000 deaths globally from
coronavirus and we are we are watching
this thing surge in a lot of Western
countries because most of these Western
countries are following the path that
has already been trod unfortunately by
Italy and Spain
I don't wanna say most of them are
treading that pepper certainly enough of
them are looking at that path that it's
obviously very scary over the weekend
Italy continued to to escalate the
number of deaths they now have almost
11,000 total deaths in Italy out of
ninety seven thousand confirmed cases
again those confirmed cases are that
confirm case number is not really a good
and useful number I discussed this with
both Vice President Mike Pence and dr.
deborah birx
on the sunday special yesterday but the
fact is that confirmed cases is a bad
number because that's the people who are
actually coming in for a test apparently
they're five to ten people for every
person who comes in for a test or non
symptomatic or experiencing very slight
symptoms don't come in for a test or who
came in for a test and didn't get a test
so confirmed case number is not actually
the number we should be looking at also
there are tons of countries that are
wildly under reporting and stuff as
we'll get to when we get to talking
about China which is continuing to lie
about all of this stuff you've seen the
media triumphal II many of them I mean
really it's it's almost triumphal II
announcing that the United States is
number one in coronavirus cases as
though this is an indicator of the evils
of the American system the reality is
that there's no question that China is
number one
in lying to the world about all of us
we'll get to that a little bit later
however you've seen an uptick and death
in Spain where there's now seven
thousand three hundred and forty deaths
as of this hour including 537 deaths
yesterday you've seen an uptick in death
in in Iran they've been lying about this
they say that they only have 2,700
deaths in Iran that is very unlikely
well sources on the inside in Iran say
that it is multiple times that number in
the UK you've got 1400 deaths with 187
deaths added just yesterday and in the
United States right here at home we have
had two hundred and two thousand six
hundred total deaths in the United
States which certainly is a
multiplication of what we had you know
last week I mean early last week we were
talking about 200 deaths 250 deaths and
then the exponential growth began and so
we have seen day over day total
coronavirus cases going up that's
because we are doing additional testing
which is good we've seen total
coronavirus deaths going up
exponentially as well which obviously is
quite bad on March 27th over 400 daily
deaths from coronavirus March 28th 525
deaths from coronavirus and March 29 362
deaths this according to the Johns
Hopkins map of the situation so
obviously very very scary times and
president Trump acknowledging how scary
these times are he is now pushed back
his deadline on when he thinks people
are gonna get back to work it was always
an optimistic deadline nobody seriously
thought who had studied this issue that
we were getting back to work on April
12th even dr. fowey had got out there he
said that was President Trump sort of
trying to be optimistic the president
Trump extended the social distancing
guidelines that he put forward basically
stay at home stay away from other people
no big events he had extended that
through the end of April that is the
very earliest that we're going to start
to see people moving out back into the
world again and that again would be
largely reliant on warming temperatures
in the United States so start rooting
for global warming now guys there's
president Trump talking about extending
social distancing through the end of
April have to follow the guidelines that
our great vice president holds up a lot
he's holding that up a lot he believes
in it so strongly the better you do the
faster this whole nightmare will end
therefore we will be extending our
guidelines
to April 30th to slow the spread one
Tuesday we'll be finalizing these plans
and providing a summary of our findings
supporting data and strategy to the
American people hey so president from
was in fact reading from the from the
desire to relax all of that by mid April
but the numbers chest did not support
that the latest numbers suggest in fact
that this thing is going to peak around
the time the president Trump was talking
about people may be starting to get back
to work according to Axios April is
gonna be very hard but public health
officials are an agreement that
hunkering down and weather in one of the
darkest months in American history is
the only way to prevent perhaps millions
of American deaths estimates now being
echoed by the Trump administration find
that the u.s. coronavirus outbreak
should peak in about two weeks
that is if everybody hunkers down now so
if you are out and about and you're not
hunkering down right now then you're
probably lengthening the amount of time
before everybody can sort of go back to
normal
unless you're out in more rural areas
where there's not a lot of social
interaction anyway but if you're in a
major city and you're going out to the
beaches and you're hanging out with
other people and you are perpetuating
the spread of this thing you were doing
something wrong you shouldn't be doing
it deborah birx who's coordinating the
White House coronavirus response
mentioned by name a University of
Washington Institute for Health metrics
and evaluation they predicted the demand
for hospital beds and supplies including
ventilators well far exceeds supply as
of April 14th barring some sort of
radical uptick on that day according to
that particular model 2300 coronavirus
deaths are expected in one day which of
course would be a massive massive number
of deaths in the United States about
7500 people die every day so that be
increasing the death rate on the on top
of that by about 50 40 percent on top of
that I'm sorry one third would be
exactly one third it would be increasing
the death rate by about one third on top
of the normal death rate that model
predicts that 81 thousand Americans will
die over the next four months and that
is assuming strong adherence to social
distancing measures without social
distancing as many as 2.2 million
Americans could die according to
President Trump that was the number of
deaths that was predicted by the
Imperial College report that came out a
little bit earlier this month that of
course is at war with another report
that came out from Oxford University
suggesting that the death rates are much
lower than all of that bottom line is
nobody knows at this point nobody knows
how bad things are going to get right
here dr. Anthony foul a yesterday he
estimated that
even with the strong social distancing
measures we could see a hundred thousand
to two hundred thousand dead in the
United States when you use numbers like
a million a million and a half two
million that Oh most certainly is off
the chart now it's not impossible but
very very unlikely so it's difficult to
present I mean looking at what we're
seeing now you know I would say between
100 and 200 thousand cases but I don't
want to be held to that because it's
it's it's excuse me deaths I mean we're
gonna have millions of cases but I just
don't think that we really need to make
a projection when it's such a moving
target that you could so easily be wrong
okay so what what because because of
that I would take the hundred thousand
to two hundred thousand with a slight
grain of salt that University of
Washington Donnell said eighty one
thousand also found she's not getting a
period on that does he mean over the
course of the year does he mean over the
course of the next few months unclear
from from his statement here's one thing
that is clear if you're a public health
official what you don't want to do is
lowball the estimate right you want to
high ball the estimate you want to say
that the the number of deaths is going
to be higher than the number of deaths
that come in number one because you'd
prefer that people are a little bit more
scared than knots that they stay home
but number two because you don't want to
look as though you are downplaying the
effect of the virus so you always want
to be on the upper end of that
particular estimate that is a big number
that's a big number that's twice the
number of deaths that we see from the
flu in an average year in the United
States if you're talking about two
hundred thousand is four times the
average that you're seeing from the flu
in the United States now that would
still suggest that foul she was holding
by his original estimate the New England
Journal of Medicine that this thing is
about as deadly as the flu it's just far
far more widespread because the
replication rate on the thing is 2.5 to
3 as opposed to the flu which is like
1.5 maybe if you have the flu you infect
one person maybe half of another person
I don't know which half but if you are a
if you are a person who is a if you are
a person who is infected the corona
virus good shot that you've infected two
to three other people President Trump
says by June first we'll be on our way
to recovery which of course is a far cry
from April 12 where I'm that's six weeks
off and and dr. Fauci said the idea that
we may have these cases many cases
played a role in our decision to try to
make sure that we don't do something
pretty maturely and pull back when we
should be pushing it is pretty obvious
that what you don't want to do is tell
up people that everything is okay
getting people to do this again is gonna
be much more difficult than getting them
to do it the first time that is pretty
obvious dr. deborah birx came out
yesterday she said no metro area is
gonna be spared cities particularly
gonna be pretty hard hit here was
Deborah births on Meet the Press the way
pandemics work and that's why we all are
deeply concerned and why we've been
raising the alert in all metro areas and
in all states no state no metro area
will be spared and the sooner we react
and the sooner the states and the metro
areas react and ensure that they've put
in full mitigation at the same time
understanding exactly what their
hospitals need then we'll be able to
move forward together and protect the
most Americans and that is the big
question is whether we are going to
exceed our capacity Governor John bel
Edwards he's a Democrat from Louisiana
he said I meet the press we don't
flatten the curve runners trajectory
currently to exceed our capacity in New
Orleans for ventilators by about April
4th all that's available in hospitals by
about April 10th so we're doing
everything we can to surge capacity it's
very difficult
of course you're seeing anecdotal
evidence from New York City that
hospitals are having a tough time with
the surge
it is not clear from data like hard data
at this point whether capacity has been
or when it will be exceeded so we'll
keep looking for that data right now
it's all anecdotal we'll get to more of
this in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that you're spending an
awful lot of time at home right now but
you may need to fix your car well some
of the businesses that are still out
there and that are still open may be
auto parts stores you should still stay
home and you should get the better part
at Rock auto com why because
rockauto.com is gonna charge you the
same price whether you are a lay person
or whether you are an expert also they
have a great catalog that really does
have all the parts you're ever going to
need rockauto.com has everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or daily
driver and get everything you need in a
few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door rockauto.com always offers the
lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do
there's no reason it's been up to twice
as much for it the same part when you
could be getting it for half the price
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to Rock Auto calm right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck don't bother leaving your house
just have it delivered right to you and
fix up your car yourself right shapiro
in there how did you hear about us boxes
so they know that we say and get exactly
the right part for exactly the right
price
rockauto.com see all the parts available
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us boxing oh he's saying you rock
Auto dot-com use the competitive
shopping of the interwebs to make your
car better Rock Auto dot-com okay so a
couple of pieces of of positive news in
an extremely extremely entire time
health insurers have said that they are
going to protect their customers from
out-of-pocket costs if they need
treatment for kovat nineteen because
obviously during an epidemic you want to
make sure that people aren't infecting
each other by staying home instead if
they're really sick you want them going
to the hospital by the way if you are
really sick do go to a hospital okay
especially if you're in a metro area if
you are seriously ill go to a hospital I
know there are a lot of people saying
don't go to the hospital because maybe
they're overrun or maybe you'll be worse
treated at a hospital if you're really
ill you need to go to the hospital
do not stay home and you'll know when
you need to go to the hospitals what
I've been told by doctors is that it
gets so severe you having trouble
breathing
go to the hospital don't wait until it
has already been difficult to profuse
your lungs with oxygen get there well
you are get there while you are still
sentient and breathing would be the it
would be the rule two of the nation's
largest health insurer Cigna and Humana
agreed to protect their customers from
out-of-pocket costs if they need
treatment a decision that represents a
rapid change in how companies are
responding the pandemic according to the
New York Times describing the insurers
decision is a big deal President Trump
on Sunday said companies don't waive
co-pays too easily we asked them they
did it well insurers and government
officials have taken steps in recent
weeks to limit people's out-of-pocket
costs when they get tested the bills
associated with treatment for Kovan can
run in the tens of thousands of dollars
for a single hospital stay david MCOR
danny the chief executive of Cigna said
let's take the economic burden and the
economic uncertainty off the table under
the new policy customers don't have to
worry about the financial burden of the
virus while their lives are being turned
upside down said Bruce Broussard the
chief executive of Humana remember one
industry was super-duper-duper terrible
and evil and horrible and terrible and
evil turns out private industry is
really stepping into the breach in a lot
of these situations last week another
large insurer Aetna which is now part of
CVS health said it would waive cost
share and related to hospital say stays
employers that self insure provide
coverage to the majority of workers in
this country they would not be affected
by the insurers decision they would have
to decide individually whether they
would take similar action it's gonna be
a client by client decision said
horizonte' so that is the death at least
is a piece of good news the insurers are
trying to relieve the burden from that
another piece of good news the FDA has
issued emergency authorization of
hydroxy
chloroquine and the media are upset
about this for some reason some members
of the media I mean listen to the listen
to the sub-headline over a political FDA
issues emergency authorization of anti
malaria drug for coronavirus care the
drugs have been championed by President
Donald Trump for treatment
despite scant evidence okay the
emergency use authorization means people
are on their deathbed like they are
going to die and the FDA is saying these
people who are going to die you know
it'd be better than death trying this
thing that has not yet been tried in
clinical trials but has shown some
promise and politico's first responses
why would the FDA waive these rules what
are you an idiot they're waiving the
rules because people are on their death
beds and they want the treatment that
they think may have shown some promise
here as president Trump yesterday in the
in the Rose Garden announcing that
hydroxychloroquine is being used in New
York City I want to point out that the
hydroxy chloroquine is being
administered to 1,100 patients people in
New York along with the z-pak which is
as if through Meissen and it's very
early yet it's only hit started two days
ago but we will see what happens the
agency is allowing for the drugs to be
donated to the strategic national
stockpile to be distributed and
prescribed by doctors to hospitalized
teen and adult patients of kovin 19 when
a clinical trial is not available or
feasible see like I don't know why the
media would be upset about this
considering a clinical trial is not
available or feasible we're in the
middle of a pandemic you morons hey
seriously the one of the big problems
with with the FDA I mean there's been a
push by Republicans for years for right
to try legislation that basically
suggests if you are a terminal patient
then you should be able to try anything
that you want to try you shouldn't be
held back by the FDA approving clinical
trials of particular material and
believe it or not people in hospitals
doctors are not gonna start prescribing
fish tank cleaner or as they have been
in Iran I'm not kidding they were using
toxic methanol seriously people are
telling them take toxic methanol and
people were like giving it to their kids
and their kids were getting blinded by
it because things in Iran turn out to be
quite horrible like this virus is bad
enough without stupidity causing people
to die so if everybody could could quit
with the fish tank cleaner the eating of
the bats
and the taking of the toxic methanol
that would be extremely helpful at this
point but if a doctor prescribes
hydroxychloroquine based on the fact
that it's shown some promise and you're
on your deathbed like what are you
whining about that the FDA removed the
the regulation here the move was
supported by the White House part of a
larger Trump Act effort to speed the use
of anti malaria drugs this is a
potential therapy for a virus that has
no proven treatment or cure FDA already
has allowed New York State to test
administering the medication to
seriously ill patients some hospitals
have added it to their treatment
protocols from himself said at a press
briefing let's see how it works in May
and it may not HHS secretary Alex azar
tweeted on Sunday night scientists in
America around the world to identify
multiple potential therapeutics for
koban 19 including chloroquine and
hydroxy chloroquine career scientists
have been skeptical of the effort noting
the lack of data okay seriously this is
what this is we're gonna draw the line
guys I feel like this is probably not
the place you wanna travel one meanwhile
dr. Anthony foul he is saying we are
ramping up capacity another piece of
good news people are going to get what
they need and also governor like there's
this push by the media that suggests
that President Trump has to have a good
personal relationship with governor's in
order to help supply them from the
federal level and factors like calm
yourselves down that's not what's
happening here
people who hate Trump are still getting
what they need which by the way is true
I mean I'm gonna show you two different
I'm going to show you two different
Democratic governors in a second or
thanking the feds for their response on
this here's how she's saying this is not
a personal thing this is just business
sunny one way or the other
he needs the ventilators that he needs
and hopefully we will get him the
ventilators that he needs they may be
closer to him than is realized but if
they're not we'll get him there and if
they are we'll try to help him get
access to the ones that are there I mean
I know the spirit of the task force and
when we talk about when people need
things doesn't matter who they are we
try to get them what they need okay and
that of course is is absolutely true
like for example
Louisiana Governor John bel Edwards he
says the stimulus that you guys have all
been criticizing the you and the media
have been ripping is insufficient the
stimulus is definitely going to help
people in my state here's Louisiana
Governor John bel Edwards the two
trillion dollar package that Congress
passed that the President signed into
law we know is going to help with
hospitals with unreimbursed expenses the
expansion of telehealth we
know that families are gonna benefit
small businesses employees is it enough
nutrition for our schools and our food
banks well you know it's it's a very
generous package it's the largest one in
the history of our country right there's
a 1.8 billion dollars for well we
there's 1.8 billion dollars for the
state that's going to help and so
there's gonna be additional legislation
coming forward I believe as well but we
know that this is a good start and and I
appreciate everything that they have
done in Congress in order to help us
listen to the questions they're right
and I mean it's so it's I'm sorry it's
terrible I mean the members of the media
who are spending all of their time just
asking people is it enough isn't enough
I mean they're looking for bad news at
this point how about this how about when
a Democratic governor of a state says
that the feds are doing their best in
providing help you say oh that's good
news instead of is it enough what more
can you get out of them like I don't
think those kinds of questions would be
forthcoming if this were a Republican
governor during Hurricane sandy talking
about how Barack Obama had provided all
the support necessary in fact I know
that that wouldn't have happened because
it didn't happen in 2012 when hurricane
sandy happened and Chris Christie was
hugging Barack Obama on the tarmac and
the media were treating Barack Obama as
the savior of the East Coast during
hurricane sandy for doing like basically
what the federal government should just
do as a baseline in the middle of a
national disaster right and the media
has been treating it like this the whole
time right CBS's Margaret Brennan she
adds Steve minuchin on the Treasury
secretary and he was saying look we're
providing stimulus were doing our best
here Margret Brennan was the same person
who is questioning governor bel Edwards
theraphy if you didn't hear her and
Margaret Brennan she's saying in
minuchin you don't know all these jobs
are gonna come back you don't know of
course he doesn't know all the jobs are
gonna come back nobody knows all the
jobs are gonna come back this is the
greatest shutdown in the history of the
world economy without a doubt without a
doubt I mean we have literally forcibly
shot every business in the United States
effectively and in Margaret Vernon's
like you don't know all the jobs are no
bleep she doesn't know all the jobs are
gonna come back nobody knows all the
jobs are gonna come back that's one of
the hard parts about dealing with you
know an unprecedented global pandemic
Margaret here she is on CBS do you need
to level with the American people here
and tell them you simply don't know that
all these jobs are going to come back
this program is going to be enormous Lee
successful and
stabilizing the US economy while
hardworking Americans who lost their
jobs or aren't able to work because of
the medical situation that they get help
so this money is going to go into the
economy very quickly it is going to help
American workers very very quickly and I
don't know how long it's going to take
to kill this virus I do know we will
kill this virus and when we do I have
great confidence that the US economy
will become roaring back okay but and
it's the questions that are like
everyone knows this is everyone ever
actually think that the jobs are
magically coming back after the greatest
shutdown in the history of the world
literally
I mean jay Inslee from from Washington
who hates Trump right hates Trump and
Trump is no fan of jay Inslee Inslee
yesterday he said we're grateful to the
federal government for doing what
they're supposed to be doing here and
providing us support now we're getting
help from the national stockpile we have
got thousands and tens of thousands of
masks and gloves and we really
appreciate from the step federal
stockpile we're having soldiers the six
twenty seventh from Colorado arrived
yesterday to build a hospital for us in
CenturyLink Field so there's some good
things happening from the federal
government and we have a lot of
gratitude for everybody involved in that
so again while the media are out there
suggesting the Trump administration is
doing a horrible job most of the
governors who are speaking up about this
including Andrew Cuomo by the way are
saying the feds are giving us what they
can you know maybe they started late but
everybody screwed this thing up and
that's gonna be one of the themes we're
gonna talk about in a second here is it
is very easy to see the bias of the
media and it's some of the journalists
like Jake Tapper's been extremely
critical of Trump but you'll see how she
went after Bill DeBlasio yesterday some
of the media are spending their time
pretending that the federal government
led by Trump was uniquely wrong on this
coronavirus thing let's be real about
this everyone was wrong about this
coronavirus thing up until about three
weeks ago up until it became obvious
that this was going to become a serious
issue in the United States people across
the aisle were not taking this seriously
enough and the the media are now doing
this revisionist history where it was
only one side of the Alfa's Trump is the
man in power it was only one side of the
aisle that was not taking this seriously
enough and that just is not true it just
isn't true and get two more of this in
just one second first let's talk about
the reality which is that again you are
staying home a lot right now and there
has never been a better time to avoid
office whether you like to post office
or not schlepping boxes to a place where
you have to stand in line with other
human beings or also schlepping boxes
that does not seem like a great idea at
the moment instead you should be using
stamps calm especially because you're
gonna have to send out a lot of mail
right now right I mean there's no
personal contact for all of our sakes we
need to avoid crowds any way we can
what if you need to go to the post
office what if you need postage to send
out letters and packages
don't worry stamps.com is here to help
anything you can do at the post office
you can do at stamps comm
print-on-demand
postage and skip those lines and crowds
at the post office plus you can actually
save some money with discounts you can't
even get at the post office here at daly
wire we've been using stamps calm since
2017 which is why we are a profitable
company at least in part
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service directly to your
computer in the safety and comfort of
your own home office anywhere else
you're hunkering down you simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
or any class of mail anywhere you want
to send it you'll get five cents off
every first class stamp up to 40% off
usps shipping rates and now in addition
to offering discounted US Postal Service
rates stamps comm also offers UPS
services with discounts up to 62 percent
plus with stamps com you won't even have
to pay UPS residential surcharges stamps
at home it's a no-brainer especially
right now saves you time it saves you
money it keeps you safe in these crazy
times right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage ands digital
scale no long term commitment just head
on over to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
type in promo code Shapiro that is
stamps calm enter a promo code Shapiro
stay safe stay home whose stamps calm
and enter promo code Shapiro okay so in
other pieces of good news a field
hospital is being set up in New York
City right now
dozens of people working in a drizzle to
erect the facility for an expected
influx of koban 19 patients at the
epicenter obvious corona virus pandemic
were working throughout the day
yesterday this is according to Yahoo
News and the trans France Presse the AFP
Samaritan's Purse a us-based global
relief agency is setting up the hospital
on the park's East Meadow lawn workers
and face masks are loading a white tarp
another equipment on the grass they've
already set up the Javits Center as well
so we are quickly
ramping up capacity in New York City
which is deeply important a piece of
actual good news is that in Washington
State which entered into the social
distancing measures and the stay at home
measures early they have seen a drop-off
in the number of new cases according to
the New York Times the Seattle area home
of the first
known coronavirus case in the United
States and the place where the virus
claimed 37 of its first 50 victims that
old age home is now seeing evidence that
strict containment strategies imposed in
the earliest days of the outbreak are
beginning to pay off at least for the
moment deaths are not rising as fast as
they are in other states
dramatic declines in street traffic show
people are staying home hospitals have
not been overwhelmed preliminary
statistical models provided to public
officials in Washington state suggest
the spread of the virus has slowed in
Seattle in recent days while each
infected person was spreading the virus
to an average of two point seven other
people earlier in March that number has
dropped one projections suggest that in
the seattle area it's now down to one
point four which is more in line with
the seasonal flu the researchers
preparing the latest projections led by
the Institute for Disease modelling
which is a private research group in
Bellevue have been watching a variety of
data points since the onset of the
outbreak they include tens of thousands
of corn virus test results deaths
mobility information including traffic
patterns and movements of Facebook users
to estimate the rate at which
coronavirus patients are spreading the
disease the progress is precarious but
the findings offer a measure of hope
that the emergency measures disrupting
life will in fact bend the curve now
with all of that said stay home don't be
stupid okay it is one thing to be out in
some rural areas of the United States
where there's not a ton of evidence that
coronavirus exists and treating every
area of the United States as though it
is equivalent would be foolish in
Seattle New York LA these are not the
same as podunk Iowa although major
cities in Iowa are getting hit by the
way I mean there have been thousands of
cases across the Midwest in the United
States that have already been diagnosed
but if you are attending megachurches in
Louisiana Ohio Florida do not do this do
not do this okay and I speak as a member
of the Orthodox Jewish community where
they have been canceling all of the
manana Rite which are the biblically
mandated biblically mandated events
where you are supposed to where he's
supposed to pray with ten other men
those have been cancelled all over the
place one of the reasons they've been
cancelled is because we have seen
widespread of cases from from synagogues
from Orthodox synagogues where people
continue to go despite the
recommendations not to go from weddings
where people were not supposed to go but
they were showing up anyway for the
weddings I personally know of several
cases in my community alone of people
who have come down with coronavirus
because they went to weddings not
the city wants a wedding in a different
city in the ended up coming down with
coronavirus apparently somebody there
had it a lot of people ended up getting
it because weddings happen to be a place
where it's pretty easy to pass lots of
dancing lots sweating lots of lots of
celebrating and drinking and eating and
all of that okay right now is not the
time to be attending the mega church and
anybody who sort of buys into the
prosperity gospel notion that you can
avoid coronavirus by going to church or
going to synagogue or going to mosque do
not be a stupid do not be an idiot that
doesn't mean that bill de blasio isn't
entity a bill de blasio the mayor of New
York yesterday he threatened permanent
synagogue closings if synagogues refused
to abide by the mandate synagogue should
certainly refuse to abide certainly
abide by the mandate obviously I'm right
here telling people don't go to
synagogue right I'm not the only one by
the way well we home the Orthodox
community bitola hador meaning the
people who are like the biggest rabbis
in the Jewish community they've been
telling people stay home because we have
seen a fairly large outbreak
particularly in places like Crown
Heights and and and Queens and some of
these other areas that are heavily
Jewish
in any case bill de blasio though
because he's an idiot he goes too far he
says okay well I want you to stay home
I'm gonna shut down your synagogues
permanently yeah you don't have the
power to do that bill de blasio that's
unconstitutional but with that said take
it with a grain of salt folks do not go
out and congregate right now now is not
the time even if you believe that this
thing is overblown by the way even if
you believe that in the end we're gonna
look back and say we went wild on this
thing you need to give the program a
chance to work even if you think that
the tylenol wasn't necessary you should
take the tylenol right now just in case
it is I mean let's make the Pascal's
wager here guys and even if you're a
skeptic we're already in the midst of
this thing give it a chance to work
here's Bill DeBlasio yesterday going too
far
instructed that if they see worship
surfaces going services going on they
will go to the officials of that
congregation to inform them they need to
stop the services and disperse if that
does not happen they will take
additional action up to the point of
fines and potentially closing the
building permanently
yeah and how you can close the building
permanently again that that would be
unconstitutional but it would be a
foolish move right now to violate the
orders that
in place that you want to get out of
this thing fast seriously let's let this
let's let the measures work is the basic
theme here we'll get to what comes next
and what those measures should look like
and how we get out of this thing in just
one second but first let's talk about
the fact that it's difficult to predict
life it just it really is there are many
things in life where you think how did I
get it so wrong like for example that
time I joined a law firm that was that
was not great well everybody's gonna get
things wrong that's just life but there
are also things we can get right on the
first try like shopping for life
insurance and this is where policy
genius com comes in policy genius makes
finding the right life insurance a
breeze in minutes you can compare quotes
from the top insurers and find your best
price you could say fifteen hundred
bucks or more every year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team handles all the paperwork
and the red tape for free and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home and auto insurance disability
insurance so even if you look back on
your triple denim days in distress you
know those days where you used to wear
bell-bottoms you'll never be distressed
about life insurance with policy genius
calm in just a few minutes you can find
your best price apply at policy
genius.com we all get things wrong from
time to time and I once worked for a law
firm they got it wrong too I was not a
great lawyer at the law firm but we can
all get life insurance right at policy
genius calm again that is policy genius
calm go check them out right now at
policy genius.com i can have a lot more
to get to we're gonna get to a couple of
pieces of practical advice for you in
the midst of all this there are a couple
of pieces of advice on how you should
deal with packages that are coming to
your house maybe why we should start
wearing masks what what the end of this
looks like how china is still lying like
we have a ton to get to still but if you
haven't had a chance to see some of our
new content it's called all-access live
we were planning on launching this a
little bit later this year but we
accelerated it and we made it available
to all of our members not just our
all-access members headin over to daily
wire.com check it out
jeremy boring and i kicked it off last
week all the other hosted live streams
over at daly wire.com we're gonna
continue all this week at 8 p.m. Eastern
5 p.m. Pacific
all access live it's really chilled out
and laid-back it's less focused on
bringing you news and information more
just like we hang out together in fact
my dad and I had been planning a special
treat I think that we made you like some
violin and piano stuff over at all
access live when you become a daily wire
member my dad will take requests my
dad's like a full-on professional
pianist played in a restaurant
years and years and years for Mendes
jazz pianist so maybe we'll do something
fun too like that while I answer
questions I am hosting today I'm not
sure whether today will be the music day
or whether that'll be later this week we
are prepping but go check us out at all
access right now all access live at
Daley wire.com and join the club and
hang out with us because listen this is
rough for everyone everybody is chafing
at the bit to get out again it's gonna
be a while so we're gonna have to sit
our asses down and we're gonna have to
hang out together so we might as well
make the best of it head on over to Daly
wire con 8:00 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific tonight join us on all access
live I believe starring moi tonight Daly
wire.com we'll see you there a little
bit later you're listening to the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so let's talk about something real
practical for a second I sent this to my
parents I figured that it might be
useful for you as well there are a lot
of people right now who are taking
takeout meals people who are people who
are taking packages from Amazon and you
read all these articles about how long
these viruses can live on surfaces and
it freaks you out there's a good article
by Joseph Allen assistant professor of
exposure and assessment science and
director of the healthy buildings
program at Harvard and he talks about
exactly how you should handle packages
and I feel like this is some practical
advice that everybody should know he
says a recent study in the New England
Journal of Medicine is making people
think twice about how they might be
exposed to cope in nineteen if they open
a box delivered by UPS such packages at
the grocery store accept food delivery
he says the risk is low he says disease
transmission from inanimate surfaces
reals he's not minimizing that in the
New England Journal of Medicine study
there's a finding that grabs headlines
that says the groan a virus can be
detectable up to four hours on copper 24
hours on cardboard two to three days on
plastic and stainless steel but that's
detectable not that you're going to get
coronavirus from the actual touching of
the package the virus says this
professor can be detected on some
surfaces for up to a day the reality is
that the levels do drop off quickly for
example the article shows the virus is
half-life on stainless steel and plastic
is five point six hours six point eight
hours respectively half-life is how long
it takes for the viral loads increased
by half and then by half and then by
half in them I have so he says let's
examine the full causal chain that would
have to exist for you to get sick from a
contaminated Amazon package at your door
or a gallon of milk from the grocery
store in the case of the Amazon package
the driver would have to be infected and
still working despite limited symptoms
let's say they wipe their nose didn't
wash their hands and then transferred
some of the virus to your package even
then there's lag time from when they
transferred the virus until you picked
up your package at the door
the virus degrades that whole time in
the worst case scenario a visibly sick
driver picks up your package from the
truck walks to your front door sneezes
into their hands or directly on the
package immediately before they hand it
to you even in that highly unlikely
scenario you can break the causal chain
so what you should do presumably is to
cut the chain you can leave the
cardboard package to your door for a few
hours or you can bring it inside and
leave it right inside your door and then
wash your hands again if you're still
concerned there was any virus on the
package you could wipe down the exterior
with a disinfectant or open it outdoors
and put the package in the recycling can
and then wash your hands that's what
I've been doing I personally received
packages in my house when they come I
immediately slap on a pair of surgical
gloves I rip open the package I throw it
in the garbage
I walk inside I throw out the surgical
gloves and I wash my hands and that's I
think the paranoid way to do this and
paranoia at this point is is not the
worst thing in the world shop one you
need to keeping six feet from other
customer says this professor says this
professor load items into your cart or
basket keep your hands away from your
face while you shop wash them as soon as
you are home put away your groceries and
then wash your hands again if you wait
even a few hours before you use anything
most of the virus will be significantly
reduced if you need to use something
immediately wipe the package down and
wipe off all your fruits and vegetables
just the way that you normally would
wash them off in the same so just feel
like that's good information that
everybody should have because people are
so paranoid do you think that you touch
anything the floor is lava you're gonna
die and and that is not the case I mean
while I do have to point out the trend
that has been happening here which is
that the media have been suggesting that
the Trump administration uniquely got
things wrong now let me be clear the
Trump administration blew it in February
they did they blew it in February okay
in January Trump was exactly right to
shut down travel from China and he's
also corrected the media or telling
people not to shut down travel from
China this is all xenophobia and racism
and all Trump can be right about that
also we then spent a month doing nothing
we spent a month not developing the test
and this is of deep concern and deeply
upsetting cuz we don't know right now
what the death rates are of this virus
we don't even know the transmissibility
rates were sort of assuming and we don't
know anything in part because China is
lying to us right there's some fairly
good evidence that China has been lying
dramatically considering that I mean
there's there seriously an article from
Radio Free Asia suggesting that there
may be 40,000 dead people in in muhan
Province right they have said there was
like 3,000 or 2,500 but that's pretty
obviously inaccurate according to Radio
Free Asia as authorities lifted a
two-month coronavirus lockdown in the
central Chinese city of Wuhan residents
said they were growing increasingly
skeptical that the figure of some 2,500
deaths in the city today was accurate
since the start of the week seven large
funeral homes in Wuhan have been handing
out the cremated remains of about five
hundred people to their families every
single day suggesting that far more
people died than ever made the official
statistics and Wu hen resident said it
can't be right the incinerators have
been working around the clock how can so
few people have died seven funeral homes
only serve Wuhan Han Cao Lu Cheng and
Han yang which is Wuhan is is those
three cities together social media uses
have been doing some basic math to
figure out their daily capacity the news
website Caixin reported that occasion
don't know how to pronounce it reported
that five thousand earns had been
delivered by a supplier to hang cow
funeral home in one day alone which is
double the official number of deaths
total some social media post have
estimated all seven funeral homes in
Wuhan are handing out 3500 urns every
single day funeral homes have informed
families they'll try to complete
cremations before the traditional grave
tending festival of qing ming on April
5th that would indicate a 12 day process
beginning March 23rd such an estimate
would mean 42,000 urns would be given
out during that time
another popular estimate is based on
cremation capacity of the funeral homes
which run a total of 84 furnaces with a
capacity over 24 hours of 1560 earned
citywide as home in one cremation per
hour that calculation results in nearly
47,000 deaths so China has been lying
about this all along that's why when you
see the media accepting Chinese
statistics they are doing the work of a
Chinese autocracy that lied about this
thing and then release it on the world
I mean China's gonna have to pay for
this in some way it's just horrific it's
just absolutely horrific by the way the
head of emergency at will hem tried to
go public with this stuff months ago and
then magically was disappeared by the
Chinese government you know it truly is
it's truly incredible yeah also the
w-h-o right which is supposed to be the
trusted source in all of this the W the
World Health Organization that
originally bought China's lie there was
no human to human transmission in the
bar for like a month the WHL was asked
over the weekend about whether by
someone in in Chinese media I believe
this in Hong Kong which means that it's
it's run by China at this point because
Hong Kong is a democracy and name only
that's why they had the giant protests
all of last year some one of the heads
of the WHL was asked whether they would
reconsider Taiwan's independent
membership and the whu-oh refused to say
because they are in hock to the Chinese
the w-h-o is basically there making it
obvious every day they are a corrupt
organization that is willing to accept
bad information from the Chinese
government it's really it's horrific
here's some of this interview this woman
asks will the WHL reconsider Taiwan's
membership because China of course
considers Taiwan to be a part of China
which is
it is not as an independent nation and
the West certainly has a priority and
protecting Taiwan from Chinese
predations one of the great tragedies in
human history is that Chiang kai-shek's
armies were defeated by Mao Zedong and
he was driven off the continent into
Taiwan
in any case the the the w-h-o refuses to
say whether they would reconsider
taiwan's membership it's amazing it's
considered taiwan's membership
it's official from whu-oh you simply
pretend she doesn't hear the question
I couldn't hear your question yeah and I
mean that let me let me repeat the
question let's move to another one then
write this because I'm I'm actually
curious I'm talking about Taiwan as well
on Taiwan's case and they use pretending
he doesn't hear the question then he
cuts off and then he cuts off the stream
that is one of the heads of the w-h-o
okay so when everybody talks about how
the Trump administration screwed this up
okay there was there's duplicity and
then there's just screwing up
okay the duplicity comes from the
Chinese government and honest to god
they've killed tens of thousands of
people with this thing hundreds of
thousands of people will likely die
because the Chinese government is an
evil autocracy and we should never
forget that when it comes to what
happened in the United States oh we
should never forget is that the same
government that we trust to fix all of
our problems blew this one on every
possible level and has been blowing it
for years and that holds between
administrations okay this is not a
partisan thing on the one hand there are
people who are suggesting it was just
Trump and they're citing the fact that
the United States did not ramp up their
their testing capacity in February and
that they missed the boat which is true
the CDC totally blew it the FDA totally
blew it and heads should roll over there
there's an entire article The New York
Times talking about the the failures of
the federal government during February
they say early on the dozen federal
officials charged with defending America
against coronavirus gathered day after
day in the White House Situation Room
consumed by crises they grappled with
how to evacuate the US consulate in
Wuhan China banned Chinese travelers
extract Americans from the diamond
princess and other cruise ships the
members of the coronavirus task force
typically devoted only five or ten
minutes often the end of contentious
meetings to talk about testing the CDC
its leaders assured the others had
developed a diagnostic model that would
be rolled out quickly as a first step
but larger scale testing of people who
might have been infected did not happen
because of technical flaws regulatory
hurdles business as usual bureaucracies
lack of leadership at multiple levels
according to interviews with more than
50 current and former public health
officials administration officials
senior scientists and company executives
the result was a lost month when the
world's richest country armed with some
of the most highly trained scientists
and infectious disease specialists
squandered its best chance of containing
the virus is spread instead Americans
were left largely blind to the scale of
a looming public health catastrophe and
is a 100% true okay the the fact is they
that people at the CDC should be fired
over this thing the fact that the there
are people who are at the FDA who should
be fired at this thing okay the people
can blame this on President Trump all
they want the reality is that it is the
job of people inside the federal
government to help convince the
President to take this thing seriously
so people should be fired over this this
is a failure of the Trump administration
but it is also true that there were
failures in prior administrations about
the ventilator supply for example CNN
reported over the weekend in at least 10
government report reports from 2003 to
2015 that spends the Bush administration
and the Obama administration federal
officials predicted the u.s. would
experience a critical lack of
ventilators and other life-saving
medical supplies if it faced a viral
outbreak like the one currently sweeping
the country then drumbeat of warnings
undermines president Trump's claim last
week nobody in the wildest dream could
have imagined the demand for ventilators
that now exists okay
well that's true but why wouldn't the
ventilators then from the Obama
administration then right so in other
words everybody missed it and this is
one of the things that drives me nuts is
the rush to the partisan politics of
pandemics when everybody blew it see
I've said before that government is more
veep than it is house of cards in other
words it is not a bunch of clever people
around a table making calculated
decisions about how to advance their
interest it's a bunch of morons it's all
the people you work with except with
actual power and when they blow it they
blow up big time and so it turns very
quickly from comedy to tragedy because
then blowing it every day doesn't have
tremendous ramifications for you until
it absolutely does there's only one that
government has one jobs here's the thing
if you think government is good for
everything then you think government is
good for this too but if you think
government has one job and they blow the
one job it's sure to undermine your
trust in government that the government
blows it this way every single time
there's a major crisis when's the last
time there was a major crisis the
government didn't blow it now we
mobilize quickly we respond quickly but
the government always blows it because
the government is staffed by human
beings and if you're gonna tell me that
the United States has handled this worse
than any other country there's literally
like two countries that handled it
decently South Korea is one and that's
because they actually prepped in the
aftermath of a pandemic that nailed them
with SARS okay but Italy is getting hit
way harder than we are Spain is getting
hit way up both those have nationalized
health care systems
enormous government's giant
bureaucracies extraordinary tax rates so
bottom line is this government sucks it
thing
it doesn't stop sucking just because
this is a thing that's very important
for it to do and it's a bipartisan
suckage
okay the by that the suckage is not
unique to one side it's not like Trump
handled this way better than Obama
whatever or Obama would have handled
this so much better than Trump did I
have no evidence of that whatsoever
again this report from the New York
Times from CNN suggests that there was a
May 2003 GAO report saying that there
needs to be more medical equipment a
2005 Congressional Research Service
report an HHS report that same month in
November 2005 of July 2006 report from
the CBO a Defense Department report from
August 2006 a November 20 2007 Interior
Department pandemic influenza plan a
2009 OSHA publication a 2009 report by
the executive office to the president
that said that they might need
mechanical ventilation that could reach
10 to 25 per 100,000 population which if
you multiply that out right if you were
that would be 30,000 to 60,000
ventilators which is exactly what we're
talking about right now a 2015 study
from the DHHS and the Center for Disease
Control suggesting that we might need an
additional 7,000 to 11,000 ventilators
and in a high severity scenario at least
60,000 additional ventilators so
everyone blew it every single person
blew it and you can see how the
partisanship falls apart when we just
accept this simple truth right Bill
DeBlasio is asked by Jake Tapper who
again Jake will actually ask tough
questions of Democrats on occasion de
Blasio was asked yesterday about you
know like a month ago you were you were
downplaying the whole virus like for a
while we talked about the timeline on
Friday and deposit we shouldn't look
backward we shouldn't look backwards
weird because five seconds ago you were
saying we should look backwards at what
the Trump administration blew how about
this
how about there's plenty of time to look
backward and cast blame at everybody now
let's try and get this crisis solved and
let's accept government sucks at things
okay so the case that I've been hearing
from folks on the left is know
everyone's a socialist in a pandemic
yeah when when it's an emergency
situation and there's literally no other
option then you have to rely on the
government but this is exactly why you
should not rely on the government when
there is any other option here's Bill
DeBlasio explaining I don't want to look
backward any more weird because five
seconds ago you were totally under
Looking Backward Bill DeBlasio in
retrospect is that message at least in
part to blame for how rapidly the virus
has spread across the city Jake we
should not be focusing in my view
on anything looking back on any level of
government right now this is just about
how we save lives going forward we all
were working everybody was working with
the information we had and trying of
course to avoid panic and at that point
for all of us trying to keep not only
protect lives but keep the economy and
the livelihoods together
okay so weird how he shifted his tune by
the way speaking of people who have
shifted their attention Nancy Pelosi
yesterday she did a press conference and
she said the president has the president
fiddles people are dying right the
president is just messing around while
people are dying here well here she was
with Jake Tapper being asked about it
his denial at the beginning was deadly
his delaying of getting the equipment to
words it continues his delaying getting
equipment to words needed is deadly what
did he know when did he know it that's
for an after-action review but as the
president fiddled people are dying and
we have to we just have to take every
precaution what are you saying that that
his downplaying ultimately cost American
lives yes I am okay um let me go back to
one Nancy Pelosi February 24th in San
Francisco in Chinatown okay this is
weeks after the virus is outbreak
everyone knew at this point that things
were getting serious in Italy but this
weeks after the operation everyone
failed everyone failed here here's Nancy
Pelosi failing and now of course it's
president Trump downplayed it what would
you call it if you went to Chinatown
where presumably there are lots of
travelers from China in Chinatown in the
middle of a pandemic and and you suggest
that everybody should come out and join
you Nancy Pelosi what would you would
you say to that need to be here
especially at this time to be able to be
unified with our community we want to be
vigilant about what that might be on her
birth what is out there in other places
we want to be careful about how we deal
with it but we do want to say to people
come to Chinatown here we are we're
again careful safe and
come join us okay literally
acknowledging there's a problem in China
at the same time she is suggesting that
everybody should come out to trying to
town and join them for measures of
cultural diversity presumably okay this
is a bipartisan failure everyone failed
your government sucks your government
and it's not just our our government is
just as good as any other government
it's just all government suck the
difference between an authoritarian
government and the US government by the
way is that an authoritarian government
wise to you the American government
doesn't lie to you there's not good at
things because the government is not
good at things I'd rather have a
government that's not good at things
than a government that lies to me
also I'd like the capacity to get out of
government's clutches whenever possible
so two things can be true at once as
always in a panic right not in a panic
but also in a pandemic obviously you may
have the only option may be to rely on
government but this just suggests why we
should not be relying on government in
nearly any other circumstance like at
all ever because they suck at things and
then they blame each other for sucking
at things honest to god they all suck at
everything okay I have not this is not
checking my fundamental faith in the
basic principle which is that your
government is is brutally incompetent
that it can mobilize eventually to do
some of the right things but if you ever
have the option of not relying on the
government you should absolutely take it
okay time for some things I like and
then a thing that I hate so speaking of
governments that are brutal and
authoritarian Henry Hazlitt who wrote
one of my favorite books economics in
one lesson I've recommended that book
many many times to people if people say
I only have time to read one book what
should it be I usually I usually
recommend Henry Hazlitt economics in one
lesson it's a great take on libertarian
economics and and how the economy ought
to work and and why government
regulations stifle the economy he
actually wrote a novel that very few
people have read called time will run
back and the basic premise is that there
is a a son of a dictator who's obviously
Stalin / Lenin and the son is isn't put
in charge of the Soviet Union this is
written in like the late 40s and the
about same time is 1984 and that he
realizes that why communism is a failure
and he starts to gradually liberalize to
the economy of the Soviet Union but this
is like taking place 200 years in the
future when the Soviet Union now
dominates the entire earth it's a really
kind of great basic take on what Marxism
is and the effects of Marxism why
Marxist philosophy is wrong on both a
moral and economic level one of the
points that hazlit makes in the book and
again
it's it's didactic it's not the world's
greatest novel but it is a great
teaching tool one of the points that
Haslett makes in the book is that truth
just is of different value in
authoritarian States truth is of
practical value meaning that whatever
forwards the regime becomes true in an
authoritarian state and that's obviously
true in China it's why it's in a global
pandemic from what was a local problem
people eating the damn bats in in a wet
market so the it's it's a it's an
informative book it's it's a good book I
would say for sort of young teenagers
like 13 14 year old time will run back
Henry has he got some time on your hands
anyway so go pick up a copy and if you
can't get your kids to digest economics
straight then this is a pretty good
elucidation of the differences between
capitalism and communism capitalism and
Marxism state ownership and private
ownership of the means of production by
Henry Hazlitt time will run back by
Henry Hazlitt okay time for some things
that I hate so as I have been saying one
of the big problems in in the midst of a
pandemic is because you have four land
government in the midst of a pandemic
crises become you focus of government
control it's something we ought to be
very careful about here in the United
States this is a crisis it's I was
required government control and that
government control should be temporary
it should not be permanent it's why when
we were looking at the bailout plans I
was very focused on what here is
temporary and what here is permanent
because Democrats would love to make all
of these bailouts permanent they'd love
to have permanent ubi universal basic
income they would love to have huge
swathes of American industry owned
directly by the government it would be
ruinous Democrats want to make emergency
situations permanent specifically so
that governments can maximize its power
as one of the one of the times when I've
been proudest of President Trump was he
was asked about why he had not
authorized the defense production act
more more robustly and he said because
nationalization is generally a bad thing
look at Venezuela that is correct that
is correct and you're starting to see
around the world
thora Terry ins taking the reins of
power and then maximizing that power in
order to deal with the pandemic and
probably having very few plans to give
it up so you've already seen it in
Russia right there are no stats out of
Russia on how many deaths they've had on
kovat but they're apparently locking
everybody down and in the midst of all
of this Vladimir Putin has been
consolidating his political control he
started it before kovin and now he's
maximizing that meanwhile the Hungarian
Parliament just passed a bill that gives
Prime Minister Viktor Orban unlimited
power
and proclaims a state of emergency with
no time limit rule by decree a
suspension of Parliament no elections if
you spread fake news or rumors you can
get up to five years in prison
supposedly and if you leave quarantine
you can get up to eight years in prison
which sounds very much like a
dictatorship if there is no time limit
to that decree right that's some scary
stuff meanwhile obviously in China they
have been shunting people off to work
camps presumably or killing them if they
talk openly about this stuff and then
lying about everything else according to
The Wall Street Journal with much of the
world on lockdown the corona virus
pandemic has chipped away at individual
liberties everywhere in more places it
is being used as an excuse to weaken
democratic institutions in oversight an
authoritarian slide that could endure
once the current health emergency
subsides in Russia President Vladimir
Putin this month pushed through
Parliament the removal of term limits
ensuring he could remain in power for
life in Bolivia the ins from an
unelected government has canceled
presidential election slated for May in
Hungary Prime Minister Orban just moved
to ahead with the legislation I just
mentioned in Israel Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu's Likud Party used
the corona virus to prevent the
opposition which gained a majority of
seats in the March 2nd selections from
taking control of parliamentary
proceedings well that's not completely
fair right that the last one on Israel
is not completely the reason I say
that's not fair
is because what basically happened is
that Bennigan's who was the head of the
blue and white party not to get into you
know too many details of the garden
Israeli politics there are two major
parties in Israel right now Likud which
is led by Benjamin Netanyahu and Ben
Egon says been Egon says blue and white
party the blue and white parties are
basically an anti in Yahoo coalition and
Pentagon's decided listen we can't have
another election in the midst of a
pandemic I will take the deal that
Netanyahu offers which is a rotating
prime ministership where I am foreign
minister that retains Netanyahu as Prime
Minister up until I believe September
2021 Ben Egon sends up his Foreign
Minister until then they actually split
the blue and white party because half of
his own party walked out and said we're
not cutting any deal with Netanyahu
which basically gives Netanyahu an
enormous coalition and nope there's no
way he gets thrown out of office barring
an actual criminal a criminal proceeding
at this point but put Israel aside the
rest of these cases are cases where
authoritarian governments are maximizing
their power the gravity of the corona
virus pandemic which Justin in two weeks
has killed several thousand people in
Europe in the United States according to
The Wall Street Journal as our
generated unprecedented restrictions on
fundamental liberties in much of the
west these restrictions if they lead to
postponement of elections in some
countries don't buy themselves
alternations democratic nature the UK
remains a democracy through World War
two despite draconian war time at
legislation that was true in the United
States as well but the question is going
to be how long this lasts beyond because
obviously the scene authoritarians rise
in places ranging from the Philippines
to Turkey how much will these measures
stay in place after the emergency is
over this is why I mentioned earlier
when Bill de Blasio says that if you
violate his orders regarding staying
home from synagogue he is going to shut
down your building permanently that's
where you start to run into serious
constitutional concerns and concerns
about basic fundamental civil liberties
meanwhile China's propaganda a parade
apparatus has already launched an
all-out effort at home and abroad to
portray its ability to contain the virus
as a testament to the superiority of its
party state system and you're starting
to see members of the media repeat this
garbage right members of the media will
say look at how trying to lock this
thing down isn't it amazing how trying
to lock this thing down
look how authoritarianism is so great I
remember years ago Thomas Friedman
expressed his his sort of wonderment at
the Chinese one-party system and through
Walter to ranty fashion i Walter durante
was the columnist for The New York Times
who went over to the Soviet Union
completely ignored the fact that they
were starving millions of people in
Ukraine and talked about how he had seen
the future and it was working yeah well
you've seen the same thing from
journalists since time immemorial Edward
snow was journalist I believe for the
New York Times who went to Mao's China
and went and walked around with Mao and
came away with the conclusion that China
was wonderful
great authoritarian state well Maggie
seemed the same sort of stuff from many
journalists with regard to China look a
wonderful job they did locking this
whole thing down
China's lying China is continuing to lie
if you buy their lives who are
forwarding their lies I don't know why
in the world you'd want to forward the
aspirations of the Chinese communist
regime one of the worst regimes on
planet earth if not the worst regime on
planet Earth by buying the lie that they
lock this thing down with alacrity and
suddenly they are some sort of
altruistic nation I've seen so many
journalists I can't even tell you who
are repeating Chinese propaganda and
it's astonishing to me astonishing
people saying yeah the United States is
number one in cases it shows how we
failed we're the worst in the world
really are we the worst in the world did
we weld people in their houses and then
allow 5 million people to leave the
region from a pen
zone and move into the rest of the world
did we do that did we lie to the w-h-o
about human human transmission are we
killing people or speaking out about the
pandemic in the United States I missed
that part I missed that part if you are
doing me propaganda work of the Chinese
you're doing the work of authoritarians
the Kremlin has joined the bandwagon
Russian military trucks laden with
surprise are parading through the
streets of Italy this week in order to
demonstrate that Russia is in fact
handling this thing supremely well the
initial wavering and slow
decision-making that allowed the virus
to spread in Europe in the u.s. have
been described with near Glee on Russian
TV although again we have no information
from inside the Kremlin on how this
thing is going because of course the
Kremlin is not gonna release any of that
information
Moscow insists it's able to keep the
infection at relatively low levels
despite reports of many hidden cases and
has not imposed a lockdown so far our
andrey korsunov
director-general of the russian
international affairs council says as
far as the russian leadership is
concerned this crisis confirms its
worldview that Western systems are
inefficient that the liberal political
model simply can't cope okay
alternatively what's happening is that
authoritarian states are using a crisis
in order to maximize their
authoritarianism that's what they're
doing
okay everybody maximizes
authoritarianism during times of crisis
Woodrow Wilson did it in the United
States FDR did it in the United States
the question is do things go back to
normal when the crisis ends and in many
nations the answer is no in Azerbaijan
President Ilham
iliev last week labeled his political
opposition national traitors endangering
Public Health he said during the
existence of the disease isolation
of the representatives of the Fifth
Column will become a historical
necessity again this is not a great
shock okay the the fact is that nits
authoritarians are always gonna maximize
their power do not be complicit by
repeating the propaganda they put out
there in order to maximize their systems
supposed credibility at the expense of
democracies which yes react slowly but
do react better and actually respect the
rights of their citizens when these
things are over
okay so we'll be back here later to know
the two additional hours of content plus
five o'clock tonight I'll be back here
hanging out with you check us out at
Daley where I can become a member you
can hang out I'm answering literally
like dozens and dozens and dozens of
questions each session it's a blast come
join us over daily we're calm I'm Ben
Shapiro you're listening to the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis clever and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
why douse key technical producer austin
stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by micro Romina hair and makeup
is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]